le télétravail est la règle télétravail
est partout où c'est possible 2 à 3
jours de télétravail par semaine le
recours au télétravail est l'une des
principales armes de lutte contre la
circulation de lakovic 19
et de fait le gouvernement le préconise
très fortement sans pour autant le
rendre juridiquement obligatoire lors de
la première vague et du premier
confinement en mars 2020 il a été
utilisé par plus de 41 % des actifs et
de fait les entreprises ont dû
s'organiser et s'adapter pour permettre
la continuité de leur activité
plébiscité par beaucoup est pointé du
doigt par d'autres d'un des principaux
arguments en faveur du télétravail
serait la productivité mettons
réellement plus efficace en travaillant
à la maison plutôt que dans un open
space
le télétravail peut-il être néfaste pour
la productivité en temps d'y voir plus
clair dans facture avant la séquence
sanitaires que nous connaissons
maintenant depuis un an
la démocratisation du télétravail était
déjà bel et bien amorcée
les chiffres annoncés par le ministère
du travail en avril 2021 indique que le
pourcentage de télétravailleurs était de
37% en avait 2021 contre 31% en mars
2021 et 30% en janvier 2021 une
évolution qui est due aux mesures de
confinement prises par le gouvernement
pour tenter d'endiguer la troisième
vague épidémique
cette massification du télétravail et
l'on veut ni poser une question c'est
celle de la productivité
plusieurs études dont celles de
l'institut chronos en 2016 repris en
quinze sont venus montrer que le
télétravail agit positivement sur la
productivité du salarié l'efficacité des
salariés télétravail ans augmenterait de
22% et voici pourquoi il a appelé à
trois éléments au le temps de trajet et
ça dépend des gens c'est vrai que se
joue une certaine manière les gens
arrivés à leur dose si vous voulez donc
là ils ont démarré dans des meilleures
conditions la deuxième raison pour
lequel la productivité s'améliore c'est
que les gens peuvent se concentrer plus
aisément dire qu'il travaille en fait
souvent on a l'impression que les gens
travaillent plus en télétravail en fait
ils travaillent mieux c'est à dire
qu'ils sont c'est une passe de travail
plus intense qu'en exposant télétravail
une troisième raison il faut le
reconnaître dans les entreprises vous
avez plein d'occasions d'être là et de
ne rien faire
selon une enquête ifop réalisée en
février 2010 7 67% des managers
interrogés observerait une augmentation
de la probabilité leurs salariés ainsi
qu'une augmentation de leur engagement
plus de la moitié des télétravailleurs
déclarent plus concentrés en télétravail
ans et pouvoir mieux organiser leur
temps de travail pour 72% d'entre eux
ils déclarent être moins fatigués et
pour 69% d'entre eux déclarent est plus
autonome et plus responsabilisés
autre élément expliqué par la philosophe
julia de funès en entreprises et plus
particulièrement en open space
il existe un phénomène de théâtralité du
travail c'est à dire qu'il suffit de se
savoir entouré de collègues qui nous
regardent pour agir en représentation
permanente alors que le télétravail va
par la présence d'un écran interposé
annulé ce réflexe de représentation et
permettre un gain de productivité
actuellement il ya donc un consensus sur
le constat suivant le télétravail permet
d'être plus productifs néanmoins le
télétravail ne peut pas se limiter à
l'efficacité individuelle
c'est pourquoi la problématique de la
productivité collective doit se poser
que même avant la crise on savait que
le télétravail de nantes à mettre pas la
productivité mais faut savoir de
laquelle on parle en fait parce que
quand vous parlez la productivité qui
augmente c'est celle-là productivité
dite individuelle c'est à dire que
chacun travaille mieux mais par contre
ce qu'on sait c'est que la productivité
collective elle l est moins bonne
donc on travaille mieux tout seul mais
moins bien ensemble donc c'est ça qui
fait que télétravail est sans doute une
solution d'avenir mais avec une certaine
mesure le baromètre 2021 du télétravail
indique qu'un certain nombre de salariés
soit le retour en entreprise car ils s'y
sentent plus productifs
56% des télétravailleurs se sont plus
efficaces sur site et 66% d'entre eux se
sentent plus efficaces dans leurs
travaux de groupes lorsqu'un s'effectue
dans l'entreprise est ce qui est certain
c'est que quand on est au bureau on est
certain d'avoir un poste de travail
impeccable du matériel à jour plusieurs
écrans un casque un siège confortable
qui évite le mal de dos etc
mais ce qui est certain aussi c'est que
on a les collègues qui sont pas loin on
à la machine à café dans laquelle on
croise de façon informelle
tous nos camarades et à mon sens la
productivité est se mesure aussi comme
ça c'est à dire que je pense que pour
être productif il faut savoir à un
moment donné s'autoriser à lâcher prise
à l'être un peu moins c'est à dire que
si on se laisse un petit peu hâlé lé 20
minutes de discussion à la machine à
café avec avec 1 ou 2 1 ou 2 collègue
emma ça nous encourage ensuite revenir
un autre poste et à être productif la
productivité c'est pas du s'est passé
pas militaire on a tendance à penser que
que la productivité c'est encore une
fois être assis à son bureau devant son
écran et ne prennent pas bougé or c'est
ça c'est une vision archaïque des choses
le présentéisme ce n'est plus comme
avant
la conterie des emmène il ya donc cette
complexité en télétravail de recréer un
véritable quête de travail inhérents à
la présence en entreprise et avec toutes
les interactions qu'elle génère le
télétravail s'est étendue avec la crise
sanitaire il va de fait rentrer dans les
pratiques des entreprises
mais attention des spécialistes
s'inquiètent le revers de la médaille
c'est le télé travail à temps plein sept
jours sur sept îles sans limite
isolement saturation des salariés de la
productivité à long terme font partie
des risques du télétravail tout le monde
veut un peu de télétravail ça devient
une organisation du travail absolument
landa mais on a vu aussi donc
effectivement l'institut de ces pièces
elle disait que et que le télétravail
permet d'avoir d'être 22% plus efficace
que quelques qu'en temps normal sauf que
cette efficacité
c'est plus value du télétravail on la
perd dès lors que le télétravail est à
l'outrance si on passe toute une semaine
chez soit enfermé à bosser le lait les
bienfaits du télétravail les bienfaits
de l'efficacité et que cela permet
bongrand s'estomper parce que l'être
humain par définition par essence a
besoin sortir a besoin de s'oxygéner a
besoin de parler aux uns et aux autres
et pas seulement derrière un écran
mais en vrai il a besoin d'être au
bureau pour pourvoir ses collègues pour
pour le pourrait changer donc un sourire
c'est peut-être encore c'est peut-être
encore d'être auto et d'échanger
quelques mots informelle a simplement
bonjour au revoir on se rend pas assez
compte des bienfaits que et que savait
que ça génère ou plutôt si là on
commence vraiment à se rendre compte
parce que ça fait trop longtemps avec
eux que beaucoup beaucoup beaucoup de
salariés collaborateurs sont enfermés
chez eux et qu'ils n'ont qu'une envie
c'est de retourner au bureau pour pour
les raisons que ça que j'ai incité